thank you
welcome everybody we have for you
tonight A incredibly fun conversation on
probability risk and chance but before
the fun starts something serious
a serious scientific experiment which
you are all going to be part of
an experiment on ESP extra sensory
perception
you all have cards take out those index
cards and the pencils you were given and
I have something I have a quarter it's
uh well you just have to take my word
for it it's a regular quarter heads on
one side tails on the other
I'm going to use this quarter to
generate a random message and I'm going
to try my best to transmit it out there
to all of you and you're going to try
your best to receive it okay the message
is going to be five coin flips five
heads or tails now you just write down H
for heads or t for tails and just try
your best to read my mind okay you got
it there's going to be five flips and
I'm going to try my best to transmit it
to the entire audience everyone ready
okay here's the first flip
okay
second flip
all right number three
foreign
last one
okay very good
now some volunteers are going to come
down both aisles and we'd just like you
to pass your card to the nearest aisle
and they'll collect them
you may be wondering whether you got it
right or not
um hold that thought don't hold the card
but hold that thought and we'll come
back to it later in the show all right
please pass in your cards and I will see
you in a minute
we like to think of numbers as being
absolutely true absolute truth incarnate
that numbers in some sense are are truth
handed down from a platonic realm above
us one plus one is always two it's never
going to change itself and become three
but every number comes from a
measurement of some sort and because we
humans are doing the measurements
they're not entirely true
a good example of this occurred in
Britain three women had two children die
of SIDS and there was an expert witness
a very famous pediatrician named sir Roy
Meadow who testified that the
probability of having two children die
of SIDS was infinitesimal one in 73
million so he argued such a small
probability means that it's much more
likely that the women were murderers
the probability that a child will die of
SIDS is actually not a straightforward
calculation it could be that there's
something genetic or there's something
even in the environment so if in fact
your first child dies of Sids the
chances of your second child dying SIDS
are much greater
three women were convicted of murdering
their children based upon testimony like
this
in the mid-1990s people suddenly got
very scared that nutrasuite aspartame
the sweetener and Diet Coke was causing
brain cancer and one of the main lines
of evidence was that you had this rise
in NutraSweet and the rise of brain
cancers from mid-1975 on so aha there
must be some connection well in fact
there were a lot of things that tracked
at the same time
if you look at the budget deficit
and how much more we were spending in
government than we were taking in taxes
you saw that brain cancers tracked
extremely well with the budget deficit
in fact that the correlation was almost
perfect so just because you see a rise
in something associated with a horizon
something else it doesn't mean that the
two are related in fact often it's not
the case
if you've got a prosecutor who's looking
at fingerprint evidence and saying
there's only a one in a million chance
that this fingerprint didn't come from
the person I want to convict well if
you're in a city of 8 million people
that means on average there's eight
other people running around the city who
the prosecutor could say exactly the
same thing about
we do feel safe when there's an upper
there it gives us something to grab onto
and believe is absolutely true even if
that number has no Foundation whatsoever
advertisers know this this is why four
out of five dentists prefer Trident it's
why L'Oreal's extra impact mascara has
12 times more impact
think about that for a second how do you
measure impact
anytime someone presents something in
quantitative form people will believe
you even though numbers themselves may
be perfect
because we are faulty in our hands
numbers can lie
hello and welcome to this session the
illusion of certainty risk probability
and chance my name is Max de sotoy and
I'm a professor of mathematics and I
succeeded Richard Dawkins as the
professor for the public understanding
of science at the University of Oxford
um to quote the philosopher Ian hacking
we live in an avalanche of printed
numbers but how can we interpret all the
data that we get onslaughted with every
day tonight we're going to consider our
inner statistician how good are we at
understanding things like percentages
um what is coincidence does it really
exist and what sort of numerical
information is our brain quite well
attuned to understand and of course how
trustworthy of a compass is our gut
feeling
well tonight we've got a fantastic
collection of panelists for you and I'd
like to start by introducing uh
gigarenza
Ginger render is a director of the Max
Planck Institute for human development
in Berlin he's trained U.S federal
judges and physicians in decision making
and understanding risks and
uncertainties he's written the
award-winning popular books calculated
risks how to know when numbers deceive
you and gut feelings the intelligence of
the unconscious gigarenza
all right
foreign
off is a physicist and author his
best-selling book The drunkards Walk how
Randomness rules our lives was described
as readable crash course in Randomness
and statistics and his upcoming book War
of the World Views science versus
spirituality will be co-authored with
Deepak Chopra please welcome Leonard
now you've already met our third
panelist Josh Tenenbaum he's a professor
of computational cognitive science in
the department of brain and cognitive
Sciences at MIT his current work focuses
on the nature and origin of people's
intuition about the world he worries
that too much tension is paid to how our
minds get things wrong and not enough to
how much they get it right please
welcome back Josh Tenenbaum
and finally our last panelist Amir Axel
he's a mathematician and science writer
as well as a recently named Guggenheim
fellow Axel is the author of numerous
books including chance described by the
New York Times as an edifying and
amusing Guide to the basic elements of
probability Theory and his upcoming book
is called a strange Wilderness the lives
of the greatest mathematicians please
welcome Amir axel
now I'd like to get us going just with a
sort of gut reaction to whether you
think that the general public people are
good or bad at interpreting data and
numbers good what's your feeling are we
good at it or bad oh let me cry with you
do you know what a probability of rain
means so if you hear tomorrow is a 30
chance of rain do you know 30 of what
well exactly yeah does it mean it's
gonna rain 30 of the uh 24 hours or does
it mean yeah so I live in Berlin most
berliners think it means that it will
rain tomorrow in 30 of the time so seven
to eight hours others believe it will
rain tomorrow in 30 of the region so
most likely not where I live
others believe it will rain in 30 of the
days for which the prediction has been
made most likely not at all so that
illustrates that there's a high variety
but also the problem is not in the
people's mind as many psychologists
believe it's in the meteorologists they
don't know how to communicate yeah yeah
well we don't have this problem in
England because it rains all the time so
right it's 100 we all know what that
means so uh Elena what's your feeling to
people are we good or bad Los Angeles
it's very easy to predict the weather
just say it's going to be sunny no no I
went to a film there recently and we had
the only week of rain it was happening
so when I was a kid I was interested in
meteorology and uh what turned me off
and maybe moved me a little bit more
towards physics was uh that I learned
that uh if you predict in Los Angeles
that tomorrow will be just like today
you do much better than the
meteorologists are trying to guess what
the anomalies are going to be
yes and that's that's exactly the point
and and so um people are both good and
bad and I know Josh is going to get yeah
Josh what do you think Josh will get on
the good parts yeah yeah yeah but I just
want your gut reactions because we'll
we'll explore it a bit more you know so
so we've got a bad bad and good because
what we what we do is we our minds um
have evolved to treat the world in a
certain way to have certain
understanding certain heuristics where
we shortcuts right we can't sit down
every time we walk outside and go do a
probabilistic calculation we just have
to get out of the way the bus right so
um so we have these rules and these
heuristics that we live by and that we
instinctually follow and and they're
very good in most cases and sometimes um
you buy Enron and you're wrong so so
they work and they don't work and that's
why it's interesting yeah
yeah I would go with good and bad I
would say bad or not so good with
numbers but good with data when you take
into account the kind the kind of data
our brains are designed for so my job as
a scientist is to figure out how the
mind works I want to understand what
makes us smart I want to understand why
a machine an artificial intelligence
system has never been built that comes
anywhere close to the kind of real
intelligence just common sense
understanding of the world that the
human mind has and we think that there's
something about how the mind takes data
coming into our senses you know our eyes
our ears and so on and finds patterns
finds structure about what's out there
in the world that that follows actually
some pretty sophisticated statistical
inference you know what you call the
kind of Statistics in our mind or
probabilistic reasoning and we want to
understand that way that you know maybe
not from the kind of data that you read
off the stock market tables but the kind
of data that comes in through our
through our our visual systems through
our through our ears and and there I
think we're pretty good all right I'm
here as a mathematician you must have
that sort of feeling when you go to a
party and you say uh you're a
mathematician and everyone always says
I'm terrible at my maths I mean it's uh
I I I get so bored of this you know
almost being proud this badge of honor
that's uh so did you think that people
are really bad at maths and numbers and
data and
I don't think people are bad with math
but they think we're not hardwired to
understand probability for some reason
and uh there's been there have been
cases where uh people with phds in
mathematics got a probability problem
wrong and that's actually a particular
problem that God and I were talking
about just a few minutes ago uh the
famous Monty Hall problem we have three
doors this is an old game on television
behind one of them there's a car a goat
behind another one and the third door I
think has nothing the question is you
choose a door and then Monty Hall who
runs this show ran and it was a real
show it was a real show on television uh
opens one of the other two doors and
shows you a goat and then the question
is do you stick with your answer or do
you switch and well let's ask the
audience that so um yeah maybe you're
all to the you know in well-informed but
uh uh perhaps put your hand up if you
actually would stick with your first
choice um uh so we've got quite a few
hands up uh how many people uh think
well let's ask how many people think it
doesn't really matter perhaps you know
yeah so you know it's now 50 50 you've
got two doors one's got a car
um how many people think so to actually
be better to um swap to the other door
yeah we've got a two well-informed
audience
so so I I know most people's intuition
is that it's a 50 50. it doesn't really
matter I'll kick myself if I swap to the
other door
um so I'll stick with my first choice
right but that's wrong uh right there's
uh a pro this appeared uh in Parade
Magazine uh two years ago 10 15 years
ago and people with phds in mathematics
wrote complaining about the answer that
was published uh in the paper and of
course they had to be very embarrassed
because you should switch they're gonna
tell the whole other story or oh go
ahead and tell no no yeah I just want to
make sure you do okay Paul Erdos is a
very famous and Brilliant mathematician
and he could not accept this he had a
hard time with this problem and he
didn't believe it and what's interesting
to me and you do mathematicians will
probably I mean imagine is the only time
in history that he was finally convinced
when he did a computer simulation and he
saw how it came out and it's the only
time I would hear of a of a
mathematician trusting a computer
simulation and not the proof using Bayes
theoremer I guess you were saying that
mathematicians were also not terribly
good necessarily you have to be trained
in probability in order it's like
quantum mechanics
right I disagree don't be fooled with
what they're telling you
no no sorry you're wrong yeah and you
too so the solution that you should
switch is correct if the assumptions are
correct the assumption is that Monty
always on first business yeah or at
least randomly independent of whether
you are in front of the right door
assume that Monty is a mischievous Monty
only offers you their choice if you're
standing in front of the door where the
Cadillac is here then you always get it
wrong so that's not a good strategy so
the key question is did in the real show
Monty always offer this possibility
answer no
and actually Monty was asked about it
his assistant and the producer so Monty
said he sometimes offered it but when I
had a gut feeling the producer said he
never offered that choice
and the assistant said
yeah sometimes he did but nobody knows
when so here we have the real problem
it's about uncertainty not about
calculated risk
well we're going to come back a little
bit too the problem was presented to
people though it's presented in a
certain way with the assumptions right
and so it's not what actually happened
in the show but I do think they analyzed
the statistics from the show
Anyway
by the way there was a book someone
wrote recently on the money Hall problem
it's an abstract problem there has
actually many other possibilities there
are three prisoner problem also they
applied that uh if you go on the Google
and you um
there was a very interesting uh article
a few years ago where they showed that
psychologists were doing experiments
that were equivalent to the money Hall
problem misinterpreting the data so if
you look on Google you can probably type
in Psychology experiments money helper
you'll find that there was a expose
written of all these experiments that
were statistically analyzed incorrectly
because they misunderstood what they
were doing in terms of the same idea of
the money whole problem right let's come
back to probably ability a little bit
later because I think before we even
deal with probability we have just the
issue of interpreting the world with
numbers I mean I think that we've seen
in the introduction a lot of the ways
that we tried to navigate the world with
numbers I mean uh do you think that it's
uh uh you know the right way to
interpret the world how powerful are
numbers in actually uh trying to work
out the way the world works and and
navigate our way around it good so I
mean a a number is important for
um sort of assessing your medical things
I mean why why should course
so the uh there's the term
evidence-based medicine isn't that
strange if there would be evidence-based
physics evidence-based education it
doesn't make anyone here because there's
a lot of Education big education
community and I question that there's
some other evidence in their studies so
something yeah you have to be careful
over interpreting numbers and trying to
quantify everything yeah that's true
yeah I mean because Joshua in some sense
saying at the beginning that um perhaps
numbers aren't the right way that uh
it's other ways that we interpret them
yeah
I mean a number of us have looked at uh
I've looked at cases where the the
numbers okay well well you can present
the very same data as a table of numbers
or you know as a diagram for example
often what makes a good diagram in a
scientific paper when scientists are
analyzing things is something that
appeals to the the way that our brains
are actually designed to process data
again coming into the senses
um the uh
yeah I don't know if you if you uh we we
have a slot on this well we'll come back
to yeah yeah they're good examples where
numbers are useful assume you want to
fly from say New York
to uh washing and you want to get there
and you have a choice between flying and
driving the only thing you care about is
where you arrive alive
so question how dangerous is this flying
relative to private
precise question how many miles would
you have to drive so that so that the
risk of dying is the same as in a
non-stop flight what do you think how
many miles well I probably drive but the
risk it is
because it's just taking off and landing
in the United States the probability is
12 out of 100
000 of dying in if you drive uh in
France it's about eight and the smallest
all the wine and actually yeah well
actually in some European countries it's
as low as five and the lowest I've seen
I checked it online is about three and a
half in a hundred thousand so I think
driving is actually much less safe than
flying yes so how many miles do you have
to drive yeah five thousand five
thousand
Josh
I try not to drive
I have no idea 500 500 yeah you're more
pessimistic well I'm trying to fight my
intuition so okay so the best way yeah
because driving is more you're right I
went the wrong way because driving we
know is is more dangerous yeah exactly
so that's good do you understand though
yeah what's your new estimate
4.99 okay
the best estimate is
if you drive 12 miles 12 miles then you
have the same risk to uh wow to die as
in a in in a non-stop flight yeah that
means if you arrive safely at the
airport with your car the most dangerous
part of the travel is already yeah
but I mean what about I mean numbers
we've somehow been evolutionary program
where we you know it's a matter of to
fight or fly is about um being able to
count so is the brain actually well
we've used numbers ever since uh first
of all most accidents happen near your
home so uh the miles don't really come
in so I could take off and landing of an
airplane are the most dangerous so the
length of the flight doesn't matter
either in a sense but uh your question
about numbers obviously I believe in
numbers I just think we don't interpret
them right but I think a lot of science
can be broken down to numbers and the
meaning of numbers if only we could
really understand the meaning of numbers
in biology with and to think well there
are processes here and there but if you
could quantify them in a correct way
we'll have perfect information but you
won't agree with me because there's
quantum mechanics comes in okay and then
you can over okay who here drinks wine
well never mind everyone drinks wine who
here uh looks at the wine ratings you
know 89 94
anybody
yeah I do yeah only a couple that's good
because my experience was people do in
fact the economic economists tell you
how many dollars it's worth it's quite a
bit between an 89 and 90 and 91 and they
they rate them on a scale that
officially starts at something like 60
but really it starts at 85 or 90 goes to
like 99 or 100 right yes and people
think that once you assign a number to
something it it has a psychological
impact it seems like it's meaningful but
um suppose that you take a particular
even I'm people's tastes are different
so let's suppose you have a wine Raider
and you know that your tastes are very
similar and that same wine Raider tastes
the same wine on 10 different occasions
over a month in different times right so
the number if the person rates of wine a
92 that means a lot it's a lot different
if that person had gives it a 92 every
time this has to be a blind tasting but
but if you know it's consistent that
means one thing and it means something
else if it's a 92 once it's an 89
another time it's a 95 another time and
it spreads all over so when you hear a
number what I'm trying to tell you is
don't just look at the number you have
to look at what's the uncertainty and
what's the what's the variance there's a
punch line okay so Robert Parker he's
like he's the guru right yeah and he's
sets a lot of what the uh these ratings
are and his uh ratings are very very
closely followed he started the rating
system in the 70s and he knows a lot
about wine I certainly don't want to
question that but I I was um
interviewing him for an articles writing
for the Wall Street Journal and I asked
him you know roughly speaking how much
variation do you have and I had some
data on his uh a couple times where he
tasted the same wines and he said oh
maybe three points it can be it could
hit on my mood and depend on what I eat
in the morning will will affect how I
drink the wine in the afternoon well if
you think about the fact that the ymc's
rating are more or less between 90 92
and 100 and it's a three point plus or
you know so a 92 line could be an 89 or
it could be a 95. in people's minds
those are quite different wines but at
any given time the same wine could be
either one so you just have to keep in
mind that that putting a number to
something doesn't mean that that's
meaningful no I mean not everything in
the introductory video we saw you how do
you make put a number to impact I mean
it's it's not everything can be
translated into numbers right just yeah
if they put a number yeah the number and
but people feel like it means something
I think there's a um there's a gut
feeling that that means something it's
meaningful just because someone assigns
a number now uh Leonard I think you have
a little experiment that you want to try
and it's about how uh which we're going
to come back to a little bit later but
we need to start the experiment now uh
just um I won't say too much else spoil
the experiment so uh easily take us
through your numbers okay
can I have lights a little bit some
lights because we need to see the
audience you're gonna be involved in
this all right so
so in this experiment I'd like to divide
you into two groups oh first of all let
me say uh it's totally Anonymous your
answer so don't worry about whether
you're right or wrong and please if you
have any hesitation just don't do it
um so everyone who's to this side of me
will call you group one
and whatever is you know just make a
guess which side of me you are it's not
that important and everyone on this side
I'm just trying to divide you in half as
group two okay so this is a proof that
numbers are very important
okay
I'm calling you one neither yeah okay so
so
um
so now
um I'm gonna show some slides I want you
to everything has to be done in silence
okay so group two if you assigned
yourself to group two please turn away
so you don't see the uh the screen if
you if you want to participate okay
and um okay next slide
so please read this silently and you
have presumably a next card and a pencil
and just write down your answer
foreign
please read this silently and write down
your answer to this one
okay all right
um next slide
now group one please turn away
group two turns forward
okay next slide
okay group two please read this silently
and write down your answer
okay next slide
and now read this silently and write
down your answer to this one
okay next slide
all right now um someone will collect
from group one
um pass your answers that way and group
two pass your answers well toward that
aisle and group one toward that aisle
you know I never talked to the person
who's doing the calculation I hope they
know what they're doing
all right
great so all group ones are going
towards uh our volunteers down the aisle
here group twos all converging down here
and we'll come back a little bit later
uh somebody's gonna take all the data
analyze it for us and we'll come back
later to interpret the information
now Leonard you think that there's some
sort of data that we're we're actually
really bad at uh interpreting and for
various reasons like the fact that how
it's coached in terms of units and
things like that can you perhaps expand
a little bit I have I I have something I
could uh I could uh a little
um audio Aid if you wanted okay right
yes yeah so
um I mean you'll see this this
demonstration tells us uh addresses that
same point but before you really can
understand the finer points of
probability and statistics and
randomness
you have to understand even basic things
like arithmetic or or units and numbers
and unfortunately our society and our
educational educational system does a
very bad job at that I believe and um
that's a whole other panel we should
have some time but um so here's just an
illustration of that that I just thought
was great and let me I got to set it up
though so I'll tell you what's going on
there's this fellow um an American uh
who has a uh a package data plan from
Verizon
and so he pays a flat rate for his uh
use of data and he was going to Canada
and um so he calls Verizon and he says
um
you know what's the rate for Canada
uh so they said to him it's 0.002 cents
per kilobyte
and that's two one thousandths of a cent
per kilobyte and he said that's you know
I don't know what it normally costs I
don't know what that is but I just want
to double check is it two one thousandth
of a cent or two one thousandth of a
dollar
and he had a gut feeling that maybe it
should be dollar but he really didn't
know what was normal and
and they looked it up they said also
they read it to him it says 2.002 cents
and they put it actually in his file
that he asked that question he asked
them to put that in his file it's 0.02
cents per kilobyte
so so then he goes to Canada and he he
uses either 79 worth of data or 79 cents
worth of data depending I guess on your
point of view but he can get charged 79
worth of data for his data usage as if
it would cost uh 0.002 dollars so he
calls Verizon back and tries to uh tell
them that it was 0.002 cents so there's
two two audio clips actually if you go
online and search for this there's a
well if you're a mathematician a
hilarious 20-minute conversation
but the people of the world Science
Festival
um uh in in your service uh insisted
that we cut it down to about a minute
and a half so okay well anyway can you
play the clips do you recognize that
there's a difference between .002
dollars and .002 cents
zero two dollars do you recognize that
there's there's actually
yes do you recognize there's a
difference between those two numbers
no okay is there a difference between
two dollars and two cents
oh yeah
okay so is it is there a difference
between point zero zero two dollars and
point zero zero two cents
zero zero two dollars and point zero
zero two cents yes is there a difference
between
no they're not actually it it is point
five dollars the same as point five
cents
is a half a dollar
50 cents a half a dollar is the same as
a half of a cent
right so so
clearly two one thousandths of a dollar
which is your rate for air time as I Now
understand it uh you're eight for for
per kilometer per kilobyte in Canada is
is two one thousandths of a dollar
but two one thousandths of a dollar is
different than two one thousandths of a
cent
what I was quoted was .002 cents that's
two one thousandths of a cent per
kilobyte
my bill
reflects .002 dollars per minute
zero zero two dollars this is a
supervisor now
okay I think I have to do this again do
you recognize that there's a difference
between one dollar and one cent
do you recognize that there's a
difference between half a dollar and
half a cent
and then do you therefore recognize
there's a difference between .002
dollars and .002 cents
no no I mean there's no point zero zero
two dollars
I I recognize that conversation I've had
that one a few times but but so why do
you think they was just you know they
got the difference between two dollars
and two cents but you know just shifting
the decimal why did it mess them up so
much I guess decimal points are can be
difficult yeah
but if I had the answer though but I
suppose you know working with different
uh units and things even the Hubble
telescope collapse because you know
people weren't talking the same language
well but it's different if you're
talking a different language you don't
and and if they said .002 and one person
was assuming dollars one person was
assuming sense yeah that's bad yeah yeah
but if one says point zero zero two
dollars the only one says point zero
zero two cents and you say oh that's the
same thing yeah that's worse yeah yeah
yeah what about the other end of the
spectrum I mean it just I think people
uh you know we've had so many statistics
about the credit crunch of billions and
uh trillions and millions I mean people
I think they think those are but they're
all infinite aren't they yeah I think so
yeah yeah well it's very hard to
Envision or visualize or feel that you
know what I have a feeling for those
numbers yeah yeah and if you're a
scientist uh not if you're a
mathematician but if you're a scientist
uh because right mathematicians you you
work purely with the theorems and the
symbols but yeah it doesn't really
matter what it is right in fact when I
was a graduate student we used to laugh
at the math grad students because we
could do stuff you know math much better
at least our math because we it's it's
much different but if you do deal with
data whatever kind of scientist you are
then you get a feeling for that you just
you know forced to over the years I mean
it's not that hard you just develop it
by working with it day after day and if
you never do and if you never run into
what a trillion means then um yeah yeah
here's one fact so we are on these zeros
behind the point and so we have asked um
one thousand Americans representative
study uh the following question assume
you play a lottery and there is one
winner out of every
thousand Earth tickets
so what is your chance that you win so
basically translate one in thousand in
the percentage
can you do this
can anyone do it
who if you thinks he can do it
nobody
anything so what proportion of Americans
Representatives study age 18 and older
you think find the right answer hint
oh what do you think what percentage of
Americans can do this
in Washington or I will run the concert
I'll run the country yeah 24 percent
the rest doesn't know it Germans
46 don't tear now
we learn you got to watch those Germans
American doctors what do you think
American doctors
75 that means still every Force doctor
cannot do that can you think how they
practice
yeah
now I want to come back to Josh now
because you know we've had a lot about
how bad and horrendous people are at um
interpreting data I mean that the
telephone conversation is terrifying I
think but uh but Joshua actually you
believe that people are much better so
yeah so we've heard all these examples
of numbers and units you know dollars
and cents and decimal places these are
cultural artifacts that we've invented
to do very useful things or to try to
quantify our experience in the societies
that we live in now but maybe think back
to a more prehistoric time and think
about the mechanisms in our brains that
have evolved for dealing with data
example that occurred to me as I was
walking through Central Park today well
maybe not so much a park but out on the
Savannah
um
on the Savannah or in the jungle uh you
see some something move behind behind a
bush what is it something gets your
attention a leopard maybe that wants to
eat you or a gazelle something that you
might eat right now we call that in in
cognitive science or in the study of
vision that's a that's the kind of
statistical inference it's just a good
guess right sometimes you're wrong
sometimes you're you're right what your
brain is doing there is seeing data
that's in the form of just flashes of
light little patterns of motion all
across all across the visual field
behind the bush and it says there's
something there it makes an inference
about a thing that's out there in the
world to explain that high dimensional
pattern of data
and you know what what we find is that
these mechanisms are surprisingly good
and that as the as the data gets gets
stronger provides more objective
statistical evidence for there being
something there rather than nothing our
brains are more likely to detect it now
there's also a kind of a bias which is a
very interesting bias it's one that we
see in a lot of other kinds of examples
and it's one that I think also has a
very natural explanation it's a bias
maybe to be more likely to see things
than to than to not see things or to see
things that aren't there
um more likely than say missing things
that are there
let's think about why it might make
sense to say be more likely to think
leopard or gazelle when there isn't one
than to say uh no leopard no gazelle
nothing there when there is one right if
there's something there that wants to
eat you or there's something they're
eating you better get it yeah right but
if you make the other kind of mistake
you see something when there's nothing
well it's just you know it maybe gets
your pulse rate and get better you jump
out and waste a little bit of time but
there's a huge asymmetric trade-off
there and the constant benefits that it
makes a lot of sense for our minds to be
able to detect these patterns and data
and maybe make an error on one side in
exchange for
for getting it getting it right when it
really counts so you think we're sort of
evolutionary programmed to be very good
at spotting yeah we have patterns yeah
maybe potentially that kind of bias and
with the right kind of data now is this
a good time to show I think it's a good
time so here's an example from an
experiment that we've done in the lab
which takes the kind of data that you
might normally look at say in a table of
numbers but presents it in a
diagrammatic form which I think allows
us to see how how well tuned our brains
are to the amount of evidence in the
data the background for this is a is a
familiar example what we're used to
reading in the paper about say cancer
clusters or clusters of rare diseases
right we we all often read about cases
where there seems like some kind of
suspicious coincidence
um over the course of a year maybe an
unusual number of and says you know the
SIDS case for example there that's that
seems like one of these things and often
it's true that um you know what looks
like a a coincidence something quainting
to some conspiracy or some environmental
causing maybe there's some toxic waste
in the environment that has to be dug no
it's just a it was just a coincidence
right but what we would say and what
this this experiment here shows is that
our sense of what the data are actually
telling us is very well calibrated with
the objective measure of the statistical
evidence for something rather than
nothing so in an experiment that we do
in our lab we show people patterns of of
data these diagrams like you see here on
the uh on the slide and you can just go
through this and just you know maybe
raise your hand just to get a sense of
this wait no sorry go back to that one
don't show them yet
can you go back to the last yeah so just
like say going along the top row how
much of a of a coincidence how much do
you think there's evidence let's say
this is each dot represents some one
case of a rare disease that occurred in
a year in a one's a square mile of a
city let's say of New York right how
much evidence is there for some kind of
environmentally localized funny thing
going on in some part of the city we'll
say how about in the first one up in the
upper left raise your hand high if you
think there's a lot of evidence or low
if you don't think very much
okay how about the one next to it keep
your hands up and just raise me lower as
you go through the one next to it
less or more
yeah yeah most people said less okay
um the next one
yeah and how about the fourth the one on
the up uh upper right
yeah that's a walk yeah right that's
right so we can do this sort of
experiment you just have people you know
look at this pattern of data shown as as
these dots and rate on a scale of one to
ten well what the next slide shows is
just some of um some of the the results
from experiments we've done many
experiments like this what you see here
is we're varying across these different
stimuli factors which in an objective
statistical analysis provide more or
less evidence for there being some
something there some invite some
spatially localized hidden cause and
what you can see what we call there's
these two bar graphs there one called
data and the other called Model the data
here are behavioral data from people
from a 100 or 200 subjects average
judgments on a scale of 0 to 10 where 10
means there's definitely something funny
going on and zero means on nothing it's
just a just a coincidence and what you
can see is that you know just like you
had your own intuitions there people are
giving you more or less of a sign in
their gut feeling that there's something
rather than nothing in these different
cases and the model there that's this
objective statistical measure of
evidence it's what we call a log likely
ratio it's the it's it's what the data
are telling us as opposed to separately
from what we I guess we might talk about
this later when we talk about
probabilistic reasoning what you might
call the the priors in Bayes rule it's
just about the data it doesn't take into
account the costs or benefits of getting
it right or wrong just how much
structure is there in the data and it's
almost perfectly calibrated with what
people are are giving you there it goes
there's a big difference when people say
there's a big difference and a little
difference when people say there's a
little bit and if that was turned into
numbers
um you think if you presented the same
data as like a table of you know an
Excel spreadsheet yeah yeah probably
most of us wouldn't wouldn't know what
to make of it right yeah just like I
didn't know what to make of your uh you
know some some of the examples of uh the
uh miles in the car and every airplane
you know those kind of numbers or
billions or gazillions so yeah yeah so
you think that that's sort of a more
sort of later cultural development is
and there's for certain purposes for
computation calculation uh we do need
numbers right
um but we also you know what why do we
have diagrams like this it's a different
cultural artifact that's designed to
take the patterns of data or patterns
that are in data and present them in a
way that our brains know how to do the
right thing with it's taking the
mechanisms that were evolved to you know
find the leopard of the gazelle behind
the bush and put them to work finding
what's really out there in the data that
we have in our environment today yeah I
have a question about that actually my
question is to you Marcus you've been
asking us questions yeah as a
mathematician I have a problem with uh
data that looks certain ways without a
probabilistic structure behind it and I
want to ask you about firstenberg's
theorem I think you know him
so uh firstenberg's theorem allows you
to find any kind of pattern you'd like
so sometimes you can look at data if you
don't have a an inferential structure we
have a population and you draw a random
sample and the sample has to be random
from this population you really get into
problems by interpreting structures that
you see basically firstenberg's theorem
tells you uh I think it's in a movie A
Beautiful Mind where he points to the
sky and she asks for I forget what it is
like a kite or some kind of structure
you can always find one when you have
data you just have to look at it in the
right way so I think we have to be very
careful when looking at data visually
because we are we can be fooled exactly
and that's why often it's important to
turn it into numbers but I think even
when it's turned into numbers we can be
fooled I mean things like the the Bible
Code uh you know really that's a
probabilistic argument saying you know
these are uh you know unlikely events
and so so perhaps we can turn to
probability because you know that's a
way of trying to interpret number
numbers and data so Amir I mean actually
it's quite a late development in the
history of mathematics uh probability
you have a role of a dice it didn't look
like it'd be something that could be
mathematized but um
1654. right so yeah so perhaps you could
tell us a little bit about
um how we managed to make mathematical
analysis of something which uh chance
doesn't look like it could be
mathematized good math is about
certainty
uh what I had in mind was a game called
the uh birthday problem so there are
about 380 people here uh actually
they're missing uh there are some seats
that are empty so I think we're about to
365. so as many as
days as there are in a year there are
people in this Auditorium here roughly
so the question is what is the
probability that two people share a
birthday now obviously if there are 365
people here then the probabilities well
one
well
we had 300 yeah and 66 if our billion
would have to be one I think everybody
would agree with that but uh probability
Theory teaches us that the probability
is quite high with even a much much
smaller set of people so I'd like to
play this game sometimes it fails so if
I fail that's a trouble with probability
right that's exactly why I hate this
probability so uh I I think people ask
me if I get nervous I I only get nervous
now in case it doesn't work yeah I'll
take so here's what I'd like to do there
are six people here and 10 here
nine right one two three four five six
seven eight nine so that's a total of
fifteen uh the next row has uh
uh
12. and uh three here
so uh that's uh 15 and what did we say
here twelve three I think that gets you
to print it I'm sorry
sixteen and twelve sixteen and twelve
that's 30 people right roughly 20 28.
you said mathematicians that's right we
can't count
mathematicians
I know a mathematician who can't do the
uh you know the tip needs a table for
the 15 tips so we're all the same so
what I wanted what I want to do is to uh
have the first person here uh say aloud
your birthday if anyone here in the
first two rows here which is a much
smaller Set uh than the whole Auditorium
matches I want you to say bingo or
something or match so I'm gonna go
around and I want you to loudly say your
birthday not the year just the day
and month November 6th I match with you
sitting yeah you're not sitting down
there so you don't count that's uh yeah
it's probably your twin uh brother over
a sister right
everybody heard January 4th okay
October 18th
July 25th
May 21st May 21st
August 21st that's a match oh my gosh
November 14th okay excellent that was
thank you
well I got so nervous I couldn't count
but that's let me explain it I guess
yeah yeah my wife it's so okay I think
most people's situation that a little
bit you might need about you know 150
people or something yeah I think we
talked about the two uh soccer teams
well 23 with 23 people the probability
is already 50 23 people 50 percent
with 30 people it's 70 with 40 people
it's 90 imagine 40 people they're 365
days with 40 people 90 probability that
they'll match now why is it why does it
work
um does anybody have an idea
yes
so so the answer was that there are more
periods of time when people might be
likely to have the children
no that's not the answer is it I mean
that's the biologist answer and the
mathematician's answer it's actually a
good answer because you you get
congregation
unevenness so it's actually a very good
answer but even if that doesn't happen
uh you do get it just because of the way
the numbers work so uh to prove this the
the rule for finding the probability is
one minus
364 over 365 times 363 over 365 and so
on up to 23 of them or so or 30 or so on
uh the reason is that the way to explain
it in in the best possible way is in a
sort of a uh a mental experiment or uh
you know uh what you have is 365 Little
Boxes here imagine 365 boxes that are
lined here and they're little balls that
fall down from the sky and fall into
these boxes now you say there are 365
boxes that's a lot of boxes what's the
probability that it will match you say
well there are lots of places every ball
can go right we all agree on that on the
other hand to think of this kind of
problem you have to think what is the
probability of no match and if you know
a little bit about probability you see
that I did one minus 364 365 and so on
you really have to think of the
probability of no match and subtract it
from one when when does no match happen
where every ball is separate there's no
aggregation at all but if you kind of
visualize it you see as balls fall down
they're likely to be two of them in one
box it just is the way it is otherwise
everybody every bar has to fall into a
unique box and that just doesn't doesn't
tend to happen so I suppose in some
sense it's about uh I suppose our
intuition is uh what's the probability
that somebody has my birthday
the different number of you know with
the 30 people the white the number of
ways you could have paired them up is is
much larger than just 30.
exactly so that's something you're
drawing from different pairs right yeah
yeah the question is when are two pair
the same versus different that's a
different question then do they have
your birthday right exactly but I think
it's interesting because it does both
the example we had at the beginning of
the uh Monty Hall problem which is
counter-intuitive and I think this
example is very counting it's very
counter-intuitive on the other hand
That's the basis for a lot of
probability Theory uh um there's a
mathematician named uh Tracy diaconis it
used to be at Harvard I think he's at
Stanford now he's at Stanford yes and uh
he expanded this problem to explain a
lot of probability Theory uh well he
also blew the Bible Code out of the
water because he showed that Moby Dick
could also have as many um predictive
messages in it um as the Bible so uh so
it's important to turn things into
numbers because without us the author is
different well apparently yes
um but yeah my nice take on that you
know 23 I play a lot of uh soccer as you
call it um here in England um and you
have 11 players in each team plus the
referee which is 23 players so sometimes
I do this game where I ask for
everyone's birthday and the likelihood
is uh over 50 of the games that are
played will have two people on the pitch
with the same birthday so um which is
quite a nice one so but I want to come
to you good because you believe that um
actually you know probability is the way
we interpret which are very importantly
in medical
um cases that you know there's a such a
percentage chance that I might have a
disease or whatever that actually it's
sometimes the way we phrase these
probabilities
um which is key so perhaps you could
take us through a sort of an example
where
um the way that you talk about
probabilities can really influence how
good you are at interpreting them okay
so I would like to teach you something
and it's about health care
and in order to to to get the the
background so at the max plan Institute
in Berlin that's in Germany uh we we
develop methods that help people
so that they can understand
the probabilities yeah which they
usually don't yeah and I'll walk you
through a little slice of a continuing
medical education session so I've
trained in the last years more than
thousand doctors
and uh will take a bunch of assume you
are gynecologists
and you have had in medical school no
training in statistical thinking that's
typical
but also you think it's just you you
have no math Gene and all the others
know things and that's the basic setting
so
when I start this I'll uh started with a
problem that's an everyday problem for a
gynecologist so assume you conduct
breast cancer screening with with
mammography
and what you know about a certain region
is the following can I have the first
slide
so
I give you now the information in the
same way as medical doctors get them in
their books
the information is technically called
conditional probabilities we'll go
through this conditional probabilities
confuse your mind not every once but I
hope so
and so what you know is the probability
that the women has breast cancer that a
woman has breast cancer is one percent
all these numbers are highly realistic
but we just make them simple okay
that's a simple probability the second
information is if a woman has breast
cancer the probability that she tests
positive is 90 this is a conditional
probability if a woman has breast cancer
the probability that you test positive
is 90 also called the sensitivity and
the final information if a woman does
not have breast cancer the probability
that she nevertheless is positive is
nine percent
so we have a base rate or a prevalence
of one percent a sensitivity or hit rate
of 90 and a false positive rate of nine
percent now here is a woman who just
tested positive in screening you know
nothing else about her and she asks you
Doctor tell me do not have breast cancer
or what's my chances 99 90 50 less tell
me
so
eleven percent
nine point three uh-huh
any other guesses
91.006 okay we slowly get this spread
huh
the point here
uh let's make a vote yeah can I have the
second slide so keep this in mind
I give you four Alternatives one is the
probability that this woman has breast
cancer in screening is
beautiful alternative 90 about about
eighty percent about ten percent about
one percent
so who of you uh start with a
can you count uh no yeah we've already
proved that I'm a rubbish accountant
yeah but yeah
so you decide for one of these
Alternatives yeah who thinks that a is
the best answer hands up
what is your account yeah yeah uh sort
of yeah it's quite a lot it's a lot good
who thinks that b is the best answer oh
well yeah that's also quite a lot yeah
quite a lot and yeah about equal yep do
we have another category besides yeah I
will do don't worry okay
who thinks that c is the best answer
oh yeah quite a lot
he thinks that
D is the best answer
yeah yeah okay three times quite a lot
yeah exactly so
uh before we get to the solution I tell
you what the average gynecologist thinks
the answer is and it's exactly the same
here so in my studies so about 20 of
gynecologists think it's D one in
hundred another twenty percent think
it's C 10 in 100
and the majority so 60 thinks it's aob
if you just look at this you understand
that medical training fails
and if you ever go to your gynecologist
ask for numbers you know don't behave as
a little child in front of a white coat
it's your health
what I do now is use the following
the point is that conditional
probabilities Cloud the minds of many
people including doctors they have the
same Minds
the solution is not now not to send
doctors into statistic course because
they might just learn something and
forget it immediately but to do
something that has to do with the
psychology of their mind and the
interesting thing is what I teach them
is to change the representation of the
information into something that our
minds can easily digest we call this
natural frequencies that's the way that
people
learned about information before the
time of statistics and probability okay
are you ready I give it in a simplified
way you always start with a concrete
number say 100 of them
so I'll just translate in numbers and
then we go in the exact numbers so think
about 100 women
we expected how many have cancer one
this person most likely tests positive
that was 90 percent
and often 99 who do not have cancer we
expect another nine
def cancer makes ten with cancer
question
sorry which makes 10 who test positive
yeah
so we have candidates targeted how many
of these tend to actually have cancer
one no c c is the right thing yeah
and can we get the next slide
so if you want to do the more precise
numbers you start with a thousand but
you end up with the same problem yeah
can we get the next slide
and the next
now we can now make a vote but you know
it yeah so when I do this exercise with
doctors so at the end of the 90 minute
continuing medical education session I
don't give them the right answer
now they get the same problem again in
probabilities and now they know we have
to translate them think about hundred
and that works and then usually I get
something between
um 85 and 90 of them now see through
they understand now there are always a
few hopeless cases
but mostly why does it work
so here you see on your left side
the situation with conditional
probabilities
and you see a formula
that's known as base rule if you don't
know base rule doesn't matter look at
this and you know why you were confused
and the interesting and theoretically
interesting point is that we can show
why
one now see through with natural
frequencies because
the representation the external
representation facilitates one's
computations and the entire formula is
very simple so you think that it's um
the the way we actually talk about the
numbers that is important in in
establishing a different intuition I
mean when you described it uh in terms
of the the what you call Natural
frequencies I think most people just saw
it immediately but in those percentages
I'm also I'm a mathematician I should be
all right with these but it just messes
with you human I'm human at least yeah
that's why it doesn't work yeah and Josh
would you say the center of that well
conditional right uh Joshua I mean would
you say that that natural frequencies is
is uh just the brain is much better at
dealing with these kind of
interpretation that's very much what
this research shows I mean people are
tracking tracking events the things that
actually happened to us as opposed to
manipulating decimals that's one of the
things our brain does we have what's
called episodic memory right we keep
track of well this is what happened
today that's what happened yesterday and
you know I think bird would say it has
said that you're harnessing those
mechanisms when you present data in the
form of cases like this and but what
about you know we had in the opening um
uh video the idea that your DNA matches
and there's a one in a million charts
and I think for for most people you know
we don't have a sort of
um a conception of a million so for us
one in a million means almost a
certainty that uh you you match some
things about how number works in the
brain is that I mean this is this is an
area where a lot of research has
unfolded over the last say Decor too we
have certain basic mechanisms for
tracking very small numbers like one two
three four objects keeping those
straight we also have mechanisms for
tracking approximate magnitudes like
keeping track you know looking at the
set of thoughts like the ones I showed
you and being able to say well another
10 or 20 dots being able to tell the
difference between those but those
mechanisms don't scale up to a million
they maybe go up to 150 or something
like that so once you go beyond one or
two orders of magnitude you know and
that's where you really need these units
like dollars but the example you gave
that's not the problem uh it's not the
problem that people don't know what one
in a million means but they're asking
the wrong question okay because when you
have the uh say there's a one in a
million chance that uh
that someone will test what will have uh
I don't know what it was the
fingerprints or the looks or whatever it
was uh that the question isn't what are
the chances that a random person will
will match that the question is given
that you match that what are the chance
that you did it and so and the
prosecutors fallacy the problem is that
there's maybe you said three or eight
people in town or whatever it is that
that match that so given that you match
that the chances that you did it are one
and three or one and eight yeah one in a
million is a red herring exactly just
like it is in this in the in the breast
cancer you have a test uh or another
test they'll tell you that uh false
positive rate the chances that you test
positive if you're not don't have the
illness one in a thousand one in a
million it doesn't matter what matters
is how does that compare to the actual
number of incidents of the disease so if
if you test uh the the test could be
great and one in a million people only
one in a million people ever test
positive they don't have it but one in a
billion people actually have it then the
chancellor is still about 999 out of a
thousand if you test positive that you
don't have it because the positive the
false positive tests are still a much
higher frequency than the actual disease
and so it's important to keep that in
mind what happens when you talk with
your doctor
in this way oh no
you know um well my brother first is the
doctor and he you know he he tells me
that they don't
care they don't I mean not that he
doesn't care but there's no way you're
going to
but I had a you know I wrote about a
drunkard so I had my own my own
experience with this because I had a
positive AIDS test back in the 80s yeah
and my doctor uh didn't even give me
even even use the word false positive he
says well the chances that this is um uh
wrong are one in a
thousands well that was a false positive
right back on that test but given my
circumstances the chances of um uh you
know given uh my
um you know drug use level or
homosexuality and all the other things
that you put in my my population the
chances of having it back then were one
in ten thousand so he should have told
me that chances are nine out of ten that
this is [ __ ] I'm sorry can I say
that no that's fine yeah yeah it's my
emotion he's off to the um he didn't
even he didn't know it was the worst
false Pete just gave me a pronouncement
like I'm the doctor here's the answer
but that was the ignorance on his part
wasn't it in some way but I think that
what about the media because I think you
know so often uh headlines uh you know
that things like cancer if I I can you
know uh 50 increase in the chance of
cancer if I eat bacon or something
um and as you know it sounds scary it
sounds like oh my God I'm going to get
but but again that that seems to me
sometimes a malicious use because you
know the number of people who might get
cancer you know eight out of thousand
now if there's a 50 increase it's again
coming back to these natural frequencies
make sense of actually that is a very
small increase in the numbers but it's a
very scary sounding
using your cell phone yeah will increase
the kind of brain tumors by a factor of
three three times as many people so that
means instead of one in 100 million
three and 100 million are gonna get it
yes should I worry about it exactly but
as a media story it's much more exciting
to hear
um so but how do you start well I am
going to get you started because I mean
do you think that actually it's
journalists not understanding or
journalists who understand but they sell
more newspapers because if they do it in
that way it's a much more exciting story
I think they don't understand they you
think they don't understand but
somebody's selling them who's who's
giving them that statistic then is it
the scientists who are telling them the
problem is the problem is to be fair
that base theorem is very complicated
and we should maybe mention part of its
history uh when basically derived it in
the 1700s he was trying to prove the
existence of God by changing
probabilities around so the problem base
theorem is is a very complicated thing
and what it does really in simple world
we works is to mix put together two
things the prior probability which is
very small you basically be saying that
with the reliability of the test the
test may be very reliable ninety percent
of the chance it's right but if the
probability and population is very low
of course you'll still get a small
number even though it's orders of
magnitude higher or say an order of
magnitude higher in your example than
what you started with but hold on the
problem here is sometimes the priors are
not used correctly that's the main
problem with Bayes theorem sometimes we
don't what is a prior prior is a
probability that we think we know from
something else like we know the tender
population so many people are ill with
the disease or something in that case
it's okay we do know but if you give the
test in a hospital you can't you can no
longer use that prior in a whole
population somebody comes to the
hospital to get the test because there's
a reason they're not feeling well they
have some kind of sim some some of the
symptoms
so if you're going to use that prior
that comes from the overall population
you're doing something statistically
very wrong and that's that's why for
instance uh the the numbers I gave you
the hold for screening but not for
Diagnostic mammography that's important
but there are other examples about
confusion that are much more simpler and
the example that was here was about
relative frequencies
and the to answer your questions so I'm
training to journalists most of them
have they learn everything in
journalists school if they go but not
statistical thinking
to go take an example from your country
so in in the UK there is area
a few years a contraceptive pills care
and it's done exactly this way so one of
the most famous one went this way the
newspapers reported that women who take
the pill of the new generation
their chance to have a thrombosis
increases by 100 now 100 that's certain
isn't it
so many British women were frightened
and immediately stopped taking the pill
which led to unwanted pregnancies and
abortions what had this study shown on
which the journalists reported the joke
that out of every 7 000 British women
who take who took the pill of the
previous generation one had his
thrombosis and out of every seven
thousand who took developed a new
generalization it increased from one to
two
with its hundred percent that's called a
relative risk
that's the same as one in seven thousand
that's called an absolute risk and the
difference between absolute and
relativism is still not known to the
British population or the German nor the
American
uh and this only this one news
caused uh in the following year 13 000
more abortions than usual
and the answer was in this case everyone
was hurt this poor woman and an abortion
is something that stays
in with these women for the rest of
their life here the pharmaceutical
industry was hurt the only one who had
something from it was the journalist who
got it on the front page and it's
repeating it's repeating all few years
in the UK and there's no learning and
your question where do the journalists
get the number from from the top medical
journals the British medical journals
for instance I wrote last year an
editorial in the British medical
insurance about how the journal misleads
their own readers by for instance
reporting allowing that studies report
the benefits of a drug for instance in
relative risk decreases 50 Lipitor 50
yes but the um the Harms in absolute
numbers one in thousand and fifty
percent can be more or less so you think
this is a kind of miscommunication
between say the academic world who
understand these numbers and and then
they look at the journals and I would
say there is at least in healthcare but
also in finance there's a systematic uh
attempt to mislead the public
on behalf of by the journalists or by
the the the academic uh the the
journalists or more or less
hopeless they don't know but it is the
the editors
um uh the editors of the major journals
in the U.S or in in Great Britain it's
their responsibility to change things
I'd like to come a little bit to sort of
the idea because the experiment you did
with the birthdays I think shows you
know how amazing that you know see if
you've done that without telling us it's
an amazing coincidence you think that
and the idea of coincidence is used I
think it also sort of abused by people
in sort of reinforcing the idea of uh
spirituality and amazing things I mean
Josh I think you've got uh um some
slides which explore I mean also your
experiment at the beginning yeah I mean
I wanted to jump in a little bit to
defend the honor of these rule okay it
is very complex when you apply it to the
kind of numbers the decimals we're
talking about there but all the all the
models that we're talking about about
how our brain see patterns are
essentially doing a kind of Bayesian
inference I mean I you can you I think
you can see this in the intuitions like
you know medical diagnosis from
statistics like the kind that you're
talking about are you know all the
errors that you've talked about are real
but think about our intuitions you know
our friend is coughing one day or just
see someone you know on the street or
next to you here in the theater coughing
what do you think's wrong with them
probably you know they have a cold maybe
you don't want them to breathe on you
right but there are other other possible
alternative hypotheses maybe they have
lung cancer emphysema or maybe they have
you know extreme drug resistant
tuberculosis now why don't we think
those things well we don't think
confidence because we're optimists and
maybe because we have some sense that
those are less common thankfully right
now if the if they're older maybe you
saw them smoking before then you might
be more likely to think oh you know
maybe he's got emphysema or he's on the
way or if you let's say you were in the
hospital on these say um infectious
disease Ward and somebody's got a bad
cough then you know you you must um yeah
things a little bit differently and so
that so there is I think unconsciously
implicitly not in you know data in form
of numbers but this kind of more
experiential real Economist on
experiments this is one of the main
things from that comes out of uh
psychology of judgment decision making
and behavioral economics it makes a
difference when you experience events
like this that it's it's very different
than just you know seeing the numbers in
the form of decibels and we are think
implicitly not not ideally or perfectly
but taking into account all the
different kinds of things we should and
roughly the way that we should now I I'd
like to come back to um your uh how good
your psychic ability is because yeah I
mean because so people might be
wondering um first of all what that was
about wait hold them don't show that yet
um you might be wondering what that was
about and whether you got it right so
let's um first see uh how many people
got it right if I remember right the
sequence that I flipped was heads Heads
Tails heads Tails now do you guys
remember look oh my God can you raise
your hand if you if you remember getting
that right
homes heads Tails heads tails
now can you count that up is that yeah
that's quite a lot not quite a lot one
two three four five six seven eight nine
ten eleven twelve thirteen fourteen
fifteen sixteen Seventeen eighteen
nineteen twenty well double the size
room about 40. now I I actually wrote
down before thinking you know based on
how many people they said were here
what's the you know what's the p-value
the the uh the probability of getting a
number that extreme by chance
um and it actually goes off my chart it
would be less than less than one in ten
thousand actually
um oh okay so you could publish that
result in any journal and as we know
many people read about this in the times
in other places you know there's all
sorts of are there there's some recent
research uh published in the most
prominent social psychology Journal by
Daryl bem on people's psychic abilities
now those are very subtle and
interesting studies and I'm not going to
talk about them but what's really going
on here
um well it could be that their psychic
transmission going on or it could be
that you know maybe you're just writing
things down at random and this this is
actually a replication if you like of an
experiment that was originally done by
the Zenith radio company in the 1930s
the Golden Age of radio but also a
golden age of interest in ESP and they
wanted to test the ability to send
messages psychically across the country
and they had psychics in the studio I
believe in here in New York I'm not sure
about that um you know drop you know
flipping coins or looking at you know
these ESP cards you might have seen
pictures of them wavy lines and crosses
and so on and sending out these these
sequences just like that and then having
listeners all around the country try to
get the message
um and and send in postcards reporting
back the data now the first slide is
actually the data from those Xena 3D
experience done in the 1930s and uh
it's it's it's it's collapsed in a
slightly interesting way but I think
you'll probably be able to get it if you
have these five bit sequences sequences
of of binary two possibility outcomes
like heads Tails or black white or here
it's all written in terms of zero and
one what we're really interested in is
your sense of coincidence and Randomness
in the sequence of the data so we don't
really care about the difference between
heads heads heads heads heads and tails
Tails Tails Tales tails what matters is
that's a that's a run of five things in
a row similarly we don't care about the
difference between heads heads heads
Heads tails and Tails Tails Tails Tales
heads so here the data has been
collapsed across what we call parity uh
or you know replacing heads with Tails
and vice versa and what you can see here
is that some patterns were just much
more likely to be written down than
others so for example the one that that
I happen to flip tonight is this one
zero zero one zero one that's that would
be heads Heads Tails heads Tails or
tails Tails heads Tails heads and you
know the the number of people who wrote
that one in the 1930s is well you know
uh maybe a hundred times some of the
other sequences again it just if that
just happened to be the the lucky
sequence then it would provide
extraordinary evidence for psychic
powers but we would now say and
psychologists have long understood this
as just tapping into our intuitive
concept of Randomness saying not all
patterns from of a random process look
equally good equally like random now
it's it's interesting here I think that
I mean you know what what makes
something look random or not well
um a sign sorry about this a sign that
that I think there's really something
quite fundamental about our brains
mechanisms for finding structure in the
world is how replicable this experiment
is across time and space so the next
slide shows a replication I did about 10
years ago at the Canada USA math Camp a
a camp for um you know math whizzes in
high school who actually understand
quite a lot about probability and lots
of other things in math but you do the
same experiment and you get almost the
very same data except a bunch of them
are smart Alex and wrote down zero zero
yeah those are the true mathematicians
you know that's as likely as anything
else about how striking the similarities
are between you know high school kids in
2003 and whoever was listening to radio
in 19 late 1930s now let's see the next
one I haven't actually seen the data yet
so this is the data that oh you see
there are a lot of mathematicians in the
house excellent I mean yeah I mean I
yeah
um and a lot of Psychics yeah yeah and a
lot of Psychics yeah look how well
um what can I say I'm I'm impressed by
this experiment I have to say it worked
even better than I than I hoped it might
but it just you know shows that there is
really something quite fundamental now
that now nothing here tells you what the
what what what that structure Discovery
is what's fundamental but we've actually
built models that can predict these
kinds of things basically doing a kind
of Bayesian reasoning in which what
you're looking at is a comparison of the
alternative hypotheses just like you're
saying it's all about the different
possible explanations and we we
basically say what are the different
kinds of of sequential dependencies
things like runs or repetitions and we
say that our concept of Randomness is
you know we're not interested that the
brain isn't interested in just things
that happen completely around what we're
interested in is the structure the
non-random things so our intuitive
concept of Randomness which this is
tapping into is really just
anti-structure and we make a vasian
model of structure perception and that's
able to predict these kinds of things
quite well
actually so Leonard we should come to
your experiment that you also which is
about how one follow-up yeah go yeah um
so who in the audience thinks that uh
that the headsets headsets heads Heads
is less likely than the one that
actually was thrown
okay who thinks it was more likely
okay who thinks it was the same
all right good they're all the same so
every syncos has the actual probability
right well if you're actually supposed
to be sure see the mind doesn't it parts
of the world that aren't predictable
wait a minute
Josh did you actually what was it
exactly heads Heads Tails heads Tails or
did you just there's something magical
about tonight like the first birthday
because I would have said that no matter
what because I know how the data is
expected but in fact I did actually put
sequence I swear really I'm not sure yet
I want to come to Europe because we're
we're getting near to the end of our
time
um but you know I'm worried about the
zero zero zero with all you smart Alex
because I I uh yeah I normally so here's
something about science that you learn
about you know taking data is is an art
and I for I didn't I didn't talk to
whoever was telling these numbers and
and and and emphasized throughout the
outliers so if any of you guys said a
thousand countries or ten thousand in
Africa this thing is totally screwed no
no no no no
people put negative numbers
no no I won't do but I think you'll be
pleasantly pleased with the album can I
have my first slide here
okay sorry here's a few this is a a
random selection of other places I've
tried this although you know not really
they all did work with as well so
um if you'll notice that group one tends
to uh guess around 60 or 70 and group
two tends to guess around in the 20s so
there's a group one uh which was you
guys I think right you tended to guess
about three times as much as group two
so I somehow using my own psychic powers
um I managed to influence you guys
um to to to guess uh much triple the
number as as you guys and so let's let's
see the answer okay yes there you go
yeah I mean it's absolutely 157
57.39 so that falls right in there and
group two 28.89
it's about double here and the actual
number of yes well last time I counted
which was a couple years ago but I think
it's 54.
okay okay yeah and so the question yeah
so you need to explain how you influence
yes so here's the punch line how do I
influence you well uh the first question
was
um show me the next slide you'll see you
got a different first question
okay you guys are asked are there more
than 180 countries in Africa you guys
are asked are there more than five
countries in Africa and I'm assuming
that you both thought most of you this
is absurd numbers but just the the the
mentioning of that absurd number skewed
your um skewed your get your estimate so
this is called anchoring and it's an
example of the broader thing called
priming and it just shows the point of
this is to show that when you're trying
to to to understand probabilities and
statistics and really sophisticated
analyzes you know a lot depends on also
um having the right data and in your own
lives when you're trying to estimate How
likely something is or what's going on
to remembering and having the right
feeling for what the actual number was
and your your estimation abilities the
quantitative abilities are easily
influenced by irrelevant factors and
that was the point excellent
33 no
no
well we can talk well that now it's
going down by 20 cents well we we we've
just got a few minutes left so I I
perhaps like you all to just uh sum up
whether you think that
um whether we can actually negotiate you
know a huge amount of data
um that we we meet every day I mean
there's so many uh I mean we seem to be
leaving data all over the place do you
think there is hope for uh actually you
know tonight I think we've really helped
this audience to to change our
perception on how we can interpret data
and risk and uh and chant something good
do you think uh is it natural
frequencies which is key to helping us
virtual frequency is just one of the
representations that are easy I think
the key is to uh go beyond the illusion
of certainty which we didn't talk about
today and which basically means seeing
certainties where there are none and in
this world as we know there's nothing
certain except deaths and taxes
and and how how to get to what I call a
risk literate Society how to get there
we need to change uh the schools
elementary school high school and teach
statistical thinking not statistical
rituals as in Psychology
but and we are still teaching the Next
Generation in mathematics of certainty
we need to change that and instead of
trigonometry and geometry focus on the
things that are really relevant later
for doctors for children Leonard would
you agree with that I mean yeah I I
think that we one can learn you know
like after uh Garrett's uh explanation
hopefully when people go for medical
testing they'll they'll you know they
understand how it works and Joshua do
you think we should be tapping in more
to uh
yeah I mean it's in common with these
guys it's all it's all about
understanding how the brain works and
how the mind works understanding the
kinds of representations that our minds
are designed to work with understanding
the kinds of inferences that we're good
at the ones we're bad at and I would say
um particularly in the computer age
right what are the different ways we can
use computers rather to to make diagrams
or visualizations that show patterns
that we wouldn't otherwise see in the
ways I wouldn't see it or to say make
machine learning algorithms that are
able to find patterns and data the way
our brains do but scaled up to much
bigger data sets and worlds of data that
we don't have the ability to grasp
through our senses those these kinds of
human machine synergies are actually
quite exciting and for me a source of
optimism and Amir I mean your example of
the birthdays showed that maths is a
very good way to you know counter our
intuition do you think maths is the
answer I I think that with the internet
there's too much data in a sense that's
not we have no control over it so
sometimes it's really important to make
sure that you know how your data was
derived and there's something we didn't
really talk about much today and that's
the Assumption of Randomness Randomness
coming back to the whole idea of
uncertainty is the key to all of
inferential statistics so you really
have to ensure that when you draw a
conclusion about cell phones and cancer
or anything you really have a way of
reducing using all the systematic errors
and the only way we do have of doing
that is to guarantee the randomness of
the sampling
well I'd like to thank all our panelists
for a fascinating Journey so thank you
very much